my name is Dan and I'm a grad student in
the physics department at NYU and this
isn't my normal kind of setting to give
a talk so you have to bear with me here
a little bit I normally speak it physics
conferences where we definitely don't
have microphones and that kind of thing
so that's very confusing but at those
kinds of talks it's always very
interactive so I don't know what it
normally goes like here but please stop
me and ask questions as we go through
because it'll be more fun that way so
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about my thesis research which I'll
explain and how Python fits into that
and and I'll introduce some cool code
that I've developed through this whole
process so this is my tag line on all
the social media that I write code for
good and astrophysics I'm in the physics
department I said but I focus on
astronomy and I'm going to talk a lot
about the particular part of astronomy
that I study but in my for all of my
work and in my spare time I spent seem
to spend all of my time writing code in
my work though I study astronomy like I
said and in particular I studied planets
and this is a beautiful artist rendition
of a planet outside the solar system
that NASA published and this is not what
my data look like it's not what I work
with I do data science um I guess we all
do that that's why we're here right and
we can define it however we want I'm in
the physics department but I'm lucky
that I get to spend part of my time at
the Center for data science which is
across the street at NYU they let me
hang out there even though I'm not
officially part of it and I sort of most
of my work is in physics but I
collaborate a lot with computer
scientists and applied mathematicians
statisticians and that's been very
important for all of my research now all
astronomers do data science and for many
astronomers that look something like
this which is beautiful but I've
actually never been to an observatory
I'm not a real astronomer in that sense
my my version of data science looks a
lot more like this where I'm cleaning up
the [ __ ] that they had from the
telescope and and sort of more
specifically I do probabilistic data
analysis so I write down a lot of math
to try to clean up the [ __ ] and so
that's what I'm going to talk about
today
so there are two goals for what I'm
going to be talking about I on a
schedule it said 50 minutes I think it
can someone correct me if that's wrong
50 yeah okay great so then we'll be able
to cover both of these goals so the
first goal is to tell you a little bit
about my work studying planets and
convince you that they're super cool
hopefully that'll work and the other
part is to demonstrate some awesome code
that goes along with this but is also
more general and useful and so possibly
some people in the room might find it
useful in their work so I study planets
I said but in particular I study
exoplanets and that's a sort of fancy
astronomy word for any planet that's
outside of the solar system so these are
solar systems that are orbiting other
stars not our son the ones that we study
are all within the galaxy within the
Milky Way but but they're outside of our
solar system and as always XKCD has lots
to say about this there have been many
comics here's one from a couple years
ago where he was drawing all of the
known planets at that point and so
they're 786 and you'll notice it's maybe
too small to see but near the center
there's a little box that shows our
solar system and one of the things to
notice from this comic is that the solar
system is pretty different and there's
this huge range of different planets of
different sizes that have been found but
like I said this was also a couple of
years old more recently he did a more
statistical plot like this where this is
showing sort of the range of planets
that exist corrected for all the
observational biases and that kind of
stuff and so what you can see here is
that there's there's a huge range of
these are these are drawn to scale so
there are huge planets that have been
found their tiny planets have been found
you see earth and the sin
there some that are smaller lots that
are bigger and the ones that are red are
orbiting Suns stars like our Sun and
then the gray ones are are not like our
Sun they're cooler stars and so they're
actually very different so the thing to
take away from this is that there's sort
of this huge range of solar systems that
exist out there and basically at this
point it looks like every star has a
solar system orbiting it so that's
pretty cool so this is my field that I
work in and I mentioned that his comic
the first one I showed was was a couple
of years old so it was published in 2012
when there were less than eight hundred
planets known this is the number of
planet discoveries per year 2014 which
is the last bin here is a good year
we've discovered lots of planets and and
so now the number is more like 2000 and
we have 5,000 candidates and so that's
pretty cool and a lot of this big rise
in recent years is due to something
called the Kepler satellite I'm going to
be talking about in a lot of detail and
it was launched in 2009 and so that sort
of started this big spike so this is
cool we found thousands of planets and
we've characterized them and we see that
there's this huge range of things but
and I and I also said that basically
every star has a solar system around it
and in our galaxy there hundreds of
billions of stars so why don't we have
hundreds of billions of planets in this
set and a sample only thousands it's
pretty cool we've spent you know
millions billions of dollars on this and
we've found a couple of thousand measly
planets and the reason for that is that
exoplanets are pretty hard to find and
there are a few reasons for this one of
them is so in astronomy for I think
obvious reasons we can't really do
experimentation anything that we do is
going to be very indirect everything
that we're studying is very far away
we're talking tens hundreds thousands
tens of thousands of light-years away
and these are these are considered the
closest stars another reason why planets
are hard to find is that they're not
very bright so the Sun is really bright
and you know at night you can see the
planets with reflected light from the
Sun but the planets themselves aren't
very bright so if you're looking at a
star out in space you can't really see
the planet because it's right next to
this really really bright star and so
that makes things a little hard to so
again it has to be very indirect methods
that that we find and study these
planets so there there are basically two
main ways that we study planets the
first one is called the radial velocity
method where you look at the motion of
the star relative to you and what
happens is as the planet is orbiting the
star the star comes a little bit towards
you and then a little further away and
you see this wobble and we've been able
to measure the motion of stars down to
meters per second so that's like walking
speeds you know so that's pretty crazy
that we can we can measure stars that
much but the most productive way of
finding planets up to this point is
called the transit method and that's the
only thing I'm going to talk about today
and it's pretty cool so the basic idea
of the transit method is that let's say
we're an alien looking in at the Sun it
might look something like this and if
we're an alien on some other solar
system and we're looking at the Sun we
just happen to be lined up perfectly
we'd notice that once a year the earth
comes in and crosses in front of the Sun
right so you can imagine it's pretty
hard to be lined up properly because you
have to be just in the plane of the
orbit but by definition of
here this is going to happen once a year
the planet is going to come across in
front of the star and actually the
geometric factor so just happening to be
aligned in exactly the right place if
aliens were uniformly distributed over
all the stars one in 200 of them would
happen to be lined up in exactly the
right way to see us and so so if you are
you can see this tiny little change in
the bit and you see this tiny little
dark planet cross in front of the star
once a year and that would last for
about 13 hours okay now if you're really
lucky this alien might also see Jupiter
right and so Jupiter's a lot bigger and
so it blocks a lot more of the star but
it has a much longer year so if this
would happen once every 12 years they
would see Jupiter if they happen to be
lined up perfectly i think the number is
something like one in 3,000 of the
aliens would of these alien
civilizations would would be in exactly
the right place one in 3,000 so that was
a little bit of a simplification of
course stars as I mentioned before are
really far away so we don't see a
picture like that one that I was showing
that was a picture of the Sun and I was
drawing the earth to scale but in
reality stars are much smaller than any
pixels we can make theirs so far away
they're just a little tiny dot this
unresolved they're a handful of stars
where we've been able to image them a
little bit more precisely but in general
we basically just have a dot and so what
happens is what's happening is the earth
is transiting over there it's crossing
in front of the star so it's Jupiter all
this kind of stuff but we can't resolve
that we can't like see that little dot
instead what we see we see the
brightness of the star and the star gets
fainter for when the planets in front of
it and it goes back to being bright
again when the planet leaves and you can
work it out it's basically just geometry
how that works it's like a little black
disc crossing in front of a bright disc
and what ends up happening is you end up
with a signal that looks like this so
this is what the earth would look like
in a perfect world this is what the
earth would look like when it was
crossing the Sun from an alien looking
at it with the transit method who just
happens to be lined up in exactly the
perfect orientation now I mentioned that
this lasts for 13 hours so that's
roughly what we have there and it
happens once a year and so and the
detailed shape of this we know very well
because like i said it's basically just
geometry but in order to see this we
have to be lucky be in the right
location and we have to be looking there
at the right time so most of the year it
would be a super boring and then we just
happen to be looking at at the right
time and if if we're looking for Jupiter
then we have to be even more lucky
because we have to look at the star for
12 years to even see it happen once
right unless we're really lucky and it
just happens at exactly the right time
so these are some of the things that we
need to do Oh another thing I wanted to
comment about here is that this this is
drawn to scale so the the size of the
change of the brightness is proportional
to the area ratio of the start of the
planet so it goes like the radius
squared of the planet and so the earth
only changes the brightness of the sun
by about a hundred parts per million and
so that's a pretty small signal that
happens for a short time only once a
year and so the things that we need to
be able to do is we need to be looking
at the right place the right star at the
right time and we have to be measuring
the brightness of That star very very
precisely or the relative brightness at
least and so another way of doing this
we have to be looking at the right place
at the right time but maybe we could
look at a lot of places for a lot of
time and maybe we'll get lucky and so
that was the point of the Kepler mission
this is what Kepler looked like or an
artist rendition I guess and it was a
satellite that that was launched in 2009
like I said it ran for a little over
four years before it it failed mostly
failed it's still running a little bit
but we're not going to be talking about
that today we'll just talk about the
main mission and this satellite is
orbiting the Sun and so it's pretty far
away from us and what it does is it just
looks at one patch of the sky
continuously for the four years that it
was running in its normal mission and
inside of that satellite there's a CCD
just like you have in your iPhone or
something but you know many orders of
magnitude more expensive look something
like this right here and but you know
basically the same principle it's just a
bunch of pixels measure photon counts
and take a video and so it looked at
this part of the sky which was chosen
very specifically to have lots of stars
but not too many stars and this is what
a typical frame from the telescope looks
like so they're about three million
brightest stars in this in this field
right here but remember I said that the
satellite is orbiting the Sun so it's
really far away from Earth and so
actually downloading the data is really
expensive so so we can't actually
download all of the pixels in fact we
can only download five percent of the
pixels that are on this frame right here
and so once a once every few months we
would download a full frame like this
but in general we would only download
the little patches around 150,000 stars
in this field right here and we would
get it at a frame rate of about two
frames per hour part of the reason for
that slow frame rate is the downlink
cost and another part is that stars are
faint like I mentioned before and so we
actually have to take long exposures to
get enough signal to measure them as
precisely as we need to
remember we want to pick out hundred
parts per million changes in the
brightness yet
um yeah I i I'm I assume that they do I
actually don't know specifically what
they what they do it's it's just it's
integer data so it's not like that's not
a huge that I'm not sure how much you
could do but I'm sure they do something
ya know so it's orbiting the Sun okay
and and so I said L too so it's about
about the same distance from us as the
Sun is from us yeah so the reason why
the satellite failed was actually
because of pointing and I'll demonstrate
that in just a second but yes it was
pointing it sorry mindful okay yeah so
it's one of the things that's great
about this data set is actually all
public so I'm not an official member of
this team I do collaborate with a lot of
official members but this is just
available for download and I actually I
have a python module that downloads it
for you and gets the nice format and all
that kind of stuff but yeah i'll
demonstrate that at some point yes
that's the point of this entire talk
yeah is there no like I simple hydraulic
lighter type early detection so they
don't even have to let
so that's that's a really interesting
question no that with this one they
basically preset the stars that they
were going to they were going to focus
on and that would that decision was
based on which which stars are kind of
like the Sun because we wanted to find
solar system like things but one of the
reasons why you wouldn't want to do that
is remember these signals happen so
infrequently and they're very low
signal-to-noise so basically you want to
see the planet cross at least three
times before you're confident that you
have everything and you need the 34 year
baseline in order to get that in the
first place yeah yeah it basic exactly
and actually the software is very
specific about when we were trying to
figure out what to do with the second
round of the mission if the constraints
are pretty crazy but it might be worth
talking about that more offline as but
but basically they have to fix which
parts of the CCD they want to read out
yeah great okay so like I said the
actual frames don't look like this
instead this is what the data actually
look like right here so this is a movie
actually I don't know if you can see
that there are actually five planets in
this movie I don't you probably can't
see those either so what's happening
here this is a little cut out this is
like if you zoom in too much on
Photoshop right the of those squares is
a pixel on the detector and this is a
fairly typical star that's downloaded
I've sped it up a lot but this is about
three months of data I'm showing right
here and and what you can see is that
it's it's sort of i said before that
they're little points they're so tiny
that we can't resolve them but it looks
like it's taking up a bunch of pixels
right there and that's due to a
diffraction and optics and all of those
things you might remember from I don't
know junior high or something
but another way of plotting this same
movie is as a time series like this so
here along the x-axis I have the time
and then the y-axis is the brightness
and all of those pixels and so the
pixels that are colored black are the
ones that are dominated by the star and
but there's some interesting things
going on in this figure that I wanted to
point out so I'm going to try to walk
over here and not disconnect the
microphone so one thing that you can
notice is with time it looks kind of
like the star is moving up and I'm
moving back down again right here you
can see that this one's getting fainter
this one's getting brighter and then
vice versa and that's due to pointing of
the telescope so the telescope is
jittering a little bit but it's actually
pointing to better than a hundred or a
few hundredths of a pixel so we got this
like crazy telescope out there with
these with these pixels and it's able to
lock right on to the stars and point
perfectly that's very important that's
what went wrong that's why it's not
running in the same format anymore
another thing that you can see is you
may be noticed before in the movie that
there's another star over here that's an
issue there's contamination across here
but either way what we can do is we can
use these pixels and sort of measure the
brightness of this star the
one-dimensional brightness as a function
of time yep yeah so what happens is it
actually downloads once a month and the
way that it downloads they didn't want
to have any moving parts on the
satellite so they decided that the way
that they would download is by taking
the satellite and pointing the main
camera or that you know that right back
at Earth so it points to earth down
links and then goes back up once a month
and this is three months of data right
here
it's unbelievable yeah sorry maybe I
mean yeah they were the initial mission
was only supposed to be three years so
they did they did complete what they
were expected to do but um yeah what
letter on life yes so this the scale on
the y-axis is arbitrary I've just sort
of scaled it so that and so you seeing
more noise in the faint pixels so the
star was bright and then the faint one
you just see that's that's just counting
noise so that that's the kind of thing
that we have to deal with right here so
now if we take this data and we just
measure the brightness of That star we
get something that looks like this this
is the brightness as a function of time
and this is our sort of best estimate of
what that is and like I said there are
five planets and here does anyone see
them no maybe some people do so but
there's some crazy things going on here
so the the planets are right this is a
planet right here and this one there's
one right here ok so these big trends
aren't the planet that's actually the
star varying so this all stars have have
spots on them they have flares they
there can they're these like big
convecting balls of gas right so they're
very active object so actually there's a
lot of crap going on that's a lot bigger
than the transit signals we're looking
for already right and but then there's
also a little bit of the motion of the
satellite still imprinted on this and
lots of other things going on and
there's just that intrinsic thickness
that's due to just the counting noise in
the detector and so remember we want to
look for so this isn't parts per million
again we want to look for things that
are about a hundred parts per million
and measure those in this so we can see
that it's going to be a bit of a
challenge right
yeah so actually photon counting noise
is one of the major effects yep um so
this is this everyone should gas because
this is the best most precise brightness
of stars ever measured or most precise
measurements of brightness ever
basically so what's the connection
between this beautiful model that I
showed you earlier and this crap we're
getting on the top that's like the best
measurement that money can buy so what's
going on we have our data is over here
on the right and and there are a bunch
of factors that are coming in to to
cause all this things are going on so
there's the signal the thing that we're
looking for the star is doing some
things and then there's this counting
stuff that I was talking about and
there's some other issues with the sky
level and things like this but that's
not too important for today and this
variability this trend here is due to
astrophysics so all of the activity in
the star like I was talking about but
also the the wobbling of the of the
spacecraft itself so we've measured our
data so we have that we know what our
signal looks like is basically just
geometry I'll be right there we can
basically estimate what the noise level
should be pretty well but what are we
going to do about this variability
question what's Cuba
it's it's a two frames per hour but yeah
and so so yeah this this is about
typical for that yeah that would be
right you know it's something like 24
frames that accounted 2022 frames that
account for this yeah not yeah but
remember we did for 44 years or
something so we you know but it's it's a
handful of the data points and the full
stream if you work it out as something
like 70,000 data points and only about a
hundred of those are actually the signal
that we're looking for yeah okay so one
of the reasons why this is hard is that
we don't really have a deterministic
model for what's going on stars like I
mentioned are very they're these very
active complicated things they're hard
to we don't we understand them pretty
well at sort of a high level but
actually simulating a single star the
way that it works is you would cut out a
little patch of the surface and put this
onto a huge computing cluster and run
for six months and and it would you know
you have have like 10 seconds worth of
simulation for that for what happens on
the surface of that star and probably
all the physics is wrong anyways and so
that's hard but then there are also
these effects of the satellite that we
can't really measure at very high
precision and and all of these other
things so there's a lot of stuff going
on and and we don't have a deterministic
model for it so how do we clean up all
this crap so the standard thing that
people do astronomers love to invent
things invent techniques and and just
hack at things and so the standard thing
that you would do is take your data
there's sometimes a little regression
step where you try to regress out some
other some other light curves from other
stars that's not so important but then
they finish by running a median running
windowed median filter and just trying
to remove all of that noise and of
course you know there's some choices
about how long that scale should be and
you know and whether or not it actually
affects your signals and all that kind
of stuff
does in fact distort your signals and
introduce all sorts of correlated noise
and all of these issues but it does
pretty well so for this particular star
that I was showing earlier here's the
paper that was studying this this star
right here and they've filtered all of
the light curves and they've found these
transits and then these are models of
the five planets in that system and so
this is kind of this is kind of what
we're working with here but that works
pretty well and we found like I
mentioned before we found thousands of
planets and so here's here's a plot of
some as of yesterday the confirmed
planets discovered by Kepler and what
you can see is there's lots of them blue
points right there and along the x-axis
I have the orbital period or the length
of the year on that planet and then the
size of the planet is on the y-axis the
black points are the three planets in
the solar system that would appear on
this plot so we have mercury venus and
earth and you can see that they look
like outliers from this distribution
right and so it's possible that our
solar system is just really rare that
they are actually outliers but I have a
pretty strong prior that it's not that
rare because I live on one
um so they would be on much longer
periods right so this this ends that you
know a year and a half right so yeah so
it would fall off but and also they're
they're bigger as well but they would
also look like outliers so why is that I
mentioned earlier that exoplanets are
hard to find and it turns out that small
exoplanets are harder to find than the
big ones the reason why of course is
that um this is the earth to scale on
the Sun you can see that they're all
sorts of spots and stuff that are bigger
all the noise is bigger than this thing
and so and the signal strength scales
like the radius squared so small ones
are a lot harder to find them big ones
right and it turns out that small
planets on long orbits are even harder
to find because remember you have to be
looking at the right time and so you
have to be you have to be lucky and
actually in the standard data analysis
pipeline for this they require that
there are three transit seen for a
planet for it to even count so there's
nothing longer than sort of a year in a
bed in the data set so Jupiter for
example we haven't found any Jupiter
analogs in this data set because you'd
have to you would only ever see it once
and it would be big but it's easy to
confuse that with all the other noises
going on and in fact you can quantify
this so this was great work by a grad
student at Berkeley who went through and
characterized how hard it is to find
planets and earth would be sort of in
the bottom right of this figure right
here where you can see the survey
completeness so when it's white you find
everything so we can comfortably say
that we've we found all the planets up
there with few caveats but at Earth it's
basically zero and so there's it's so
what it looks like is that there's some
selection effects that's going that are
going on right here that doesn't stop us
lots of people extrapolate I published a
paper a few months ago that that
estimated how common earths are and
they're not they're not super common but
they're pretty common and
I estimated that there should be ten
transiting Earth's in the data set in
hand and so now I've set out to find
them and so I the title of my talk was
about gaussian processes and we're
already more than halfway through and i
haven't even touched on that yet i'm
really sorry about that but hopefully
some of this data stuff was cool but
this is where we start getting into the
time series analysis that i promised so
i'm not here today to teach you too much
about what gaussian processes are
mathematically I will touch on it
briefly but this is the standard
reference if you're interested in
learning about them is a free text book
you can google gaussian process textbook
has got all the things is great pdfs
online now I so I showed this figure
before this is the generative process
for our data or so we say and and what
we want to do is we want to we want to
model the things that we don't
understand somehow and this is where the
Gaussian process comes in we rearrange
this equation right here we take our
physical model of the thing that we know
that we're looking for we move it over
to the other side and then we end up
with just this crap that we we don't
know over here and we're trying to model
that with a Gaussian process so what is
the Gaussian process it there are lots
of different ways of describing it
describing what a guessing process is
but one is that it sort of it puts the
probability distribution over smooth
functions and this this probability
distribution is tunable it has some
choices in it and here is an example of
I think 12 functions that were drawn
from a particular Gaussian process
distribution right here and so you can
see they're all smooth they're all
infinitely differentiable or whatever
and but you can see that they have sort
of a characteristic they have some
characteristic scales in here so the
width of that sort of the strength of
this variation in in the y-axis here
they're all sort of roughly the same
and then the length over which they're
they're smooth like this is is also the
same for all of these okay so this is
this is an example of a Gaussian process
so we can change these parameters so if
we shorten the length over which they're
smooth then we get something that looks
like this you can see they're kind of
wild and then we can also change the you
know the variation like that so this is
sort of the simplest example we have two
parameters and we can play around with
it so this one that showed at the
beginning that kind of looks pretty
similar to the data that i was showing
before right so that's kind of cool the
thing that's nice about is you know it
go it might go up or it might go down
and we don't know because we don't
understand stars but we might be able to
say that that it should sort of very
with some characteristic time scale as
physicists we love to do that right so
this might be an effective model for the
things that are going on so if we take
this and just fit a Gaussian process to
it we get this line right here this line
actually has some width to it it's a
probabilistic estimate for for what the
star is doing and you can see that you
know that looks pretty reasonable
now what does all this mean why does it
call it a gaussian process we don't need
to go into the details here but
mathematically the story is that your
data points are a single realization of
a multi dimensional Gaussian where the
dimension of that Gaussian distribution
is the number of data points that you
have and so that's a really crazy thing
to visualize so in my data sets it would
be a sixty thousand dimensional vector
is what my data are um and so that
that's sort of a little bit hard to
grasp and that might be a discussion for
beers later but mathematically what that
looks like is this so our data why are
drawn from a normal distribution with
some mean function evaluated at a bunch
of times where this is the you know my
model of what a transit should look like
and then all of those points are
covariant with each other through this
covariance matrix right here which is
this you know 60,000 by 60,000 matrix
now how do we describe that the standard
the way that it works in a Gaussian
process is you write down some function
that gives you the elements of that
matrix right and and so that's called
the covariance function or the kernel
function oh I meant to show this but so
right here you just have some function
that takes in two times and it says how
correlated they are and that this is
where every sort of the magic comes in
this is this is how it all works but
then mathematically that that equation I
showed on the previous slide is this and
some people just walked in and saw this
on the slide which is a little scarier
but it it doesn't matter too much the
details that are going on here I'll come
back to that in a minute but but this is
the equation that you need to evaluate
if you're going to fit so we have some
parameters that describe this function
right here so for example in the example
that showed earlier that would be like
the length of time that the function was
smooth and then also the amplitude of
the variations would be two parameters
that would go in there but I also have
the parameters of my my planet and that
kind of stuff exactly yep so like I said
the choice of this function is where all
the magic happens so here this is the
function this is the covariance function
that I was plotting earlier so you can
see here you know the problem with this
is it kind of looks like a Gaussian but
we already have overloaded Gaussian in
the in this case so this is called the
exponential squared kernel or the
squared exponential kernel and it right
now just has one parameter so it has the
length of time over which the points are
correlated and you could just multiply
that by some factor that was set the
scale of the variations the covariance
matrix that you would get from something
like that looks like this so as points
get closer together in time time is
along the x-axis and the y-axis here so
the the point with itself would be along
the diagonal and nearby points are
correlated and as you get further away
their uncorrelated right so that's our
the simplest thing we just have the two
parameters in this one you can do way
crazier things so here's an example of
something else if you think you have
some periodic oscillations in your
signal but they're maybe not totally
coherent then you could write down
something like this right here it has a
bunch more parameters including the
period and the covariance matrix would
look something like this
so this is the standard example that's
given in every guest in process
demonstration this is the co2 levels on
the top of Mont Aloha and Hawaii as a
function of time and what people do is
they use a Gaussian process that has you
know 20 parameters or something and
extrapolates this function so predicts
into the future and that would look
something like this and this is kind of
cool this is useful so you so that it
gives a predictive model without you're
not imposing too much structure on this
you're just writing down what the
covariance between the points are but
you can predict what this is going to do
in the future and you can see that the
prediction gets more uncertain as we get
far into the future and so that's kind
of cool but we won't won't talk about
that too much um that was just to show
now so I showed this slide before and I
said that this is all you have to do
this is the whole thing this is what
Gaussian process is and that's true so
here is an example of how you would code
this up in Python this is more or less
the most efficient version that I could
come up with using the standard library
and we have some function the kernel
function that evaluates the covariance
as a function you know for two for two
different points okay
and so I also have written some code
that that can do this that basically
inside does this but evaluates the
colonel and see so it's a little faster
and this same function would look like
this all right so that's cool so we we
can implement this pretty easily the
code is called George is down there and
about me to come back to that in a
minute so don't worry about that too
much here here's just how expensive this
is this is the number the size of the
data set that we're working on and the
time it takes to evaluate this model
basically scikit-learn sucks if not it's
yeah anyways it's we'll talk about that
later but I so this is this is my my
code right here that's that's running
this benchmark here but remember I said
that my dataset is 60,000 data points
and so we're already getting pretty
expensive here things are starting to
too if I actually want to you know put
this into an optimizer and evaluate it a
bunch of times and actually fit a model
then we're going to run into some issues
and so so this I hate all this [ __ ] but
um but I heard a definition of big data
the other day which I kind of liked
which is data where you have to care
about the scaling of your algorithms and
so in my case this starts to come in
handy even though you know compared to
lots of people my data is pretty puny
but but it does matter the scaling of
the algorithms and so the standard
implementation the thing that showed
previously scales like n cubed so the
number of data points cubed and that's
because you have to evaluate the inverse
of this gigantic matrix which is
something like n tubed we also have to
compute this determinant term and that's
relevant because all standard linear
algebra packages don't do that so if you
read the LA pack documentation for
example in the first page they have a
bold warning that says never compute
determinants it's a really stupid idea
would want to do that but I need to do
that so I went across the street to the
applied math department asked some folks
what I should do because my model wasn't
working and it sounded really sick and
so and they said some words that I
didn't understand and I asked them if
they could compute determinants and they
said absolutely not that's a terrible
idea why would you want to do that but
then they went away for a few days and
came back and it figured out how to do
it and it turns out that that we could
implement this so the basic idea is that
there's some structure in these matrices
they're smooth and so we might be able
to take advantage of that structure to
evaluate this model a little faster and
so don't need to worry about this but
the thing that's cool is that the
scaling of this algorithm is n log
squared n which is faster than N squared
everyone gasped that means it never
touches every element of the matrix
let's talk about that later but this is
really cool it was implemented in this
github repository in C++ and this is
what the code looks like is its applied
mathematicians writing so it's a horror
but I did the hard work of wading
through this and and and bringing it
into writing python bindings and this
kind of stuff and now it sits inside of
my code so this is the example that I
showed previously and you can just add
this one little flag and then it
suddenly uses this n log squared n
algorithm and here's what you get for
the scaling and even for small matrices
it does a pretty great job and so this
is this is really cool this is why you
would maybe want to use this code and
this algorithm and it works very well
for modeling exoplanets this has
actually been used in three published
astronomy papers so far and this just
came out a few months ago so it's very
exciting and here i think i'm at the end
of time so here are the links to the
info
and I think we'll take questions yes
yes oh that's a great question so I was
about another package called g pi which
is um from University of Sheffield I
think and it's it's a it's the place
where all the sort of top-of-the-line
inference algorithms for guessing
processes are implemented and so it's
slower than then my code because it
doesn't is not built on top of this
linear algebra package so it would scale
like you know doing the trivial things
like like the simple scaling there but
it has a lot more flexibility so it does
actually implement more algorithms so if
you have a smallish data set it might be
a good thing to use but but most of the
basic things would be would be the same
and actually the the way of specifying
kernels is very similar yep so so oh
yeah I think I might even have internet
access here so there duck there's
documentation oh yeah so I'm using at
the matern 32 is my my standard go to
medical justification make on your
remodel or is that just from the
structure of your data yeah so um so
there isn't really it's just a simple
example of something that's smooth with
some length scale and I've found that so
one of the things that's nice is that we
care about a specific thing right so we
care about the properties of these
planets and so we can take real data
that don't have planets in them quit in
fig signals and see how well we do and
in practice the matern does the best of
the standard kernels yep
yeah did you know so I don't ever do
that I directly model the raw photometry
in the time domain and and yeah so
that's pretty cool yeah
algorithm
is also
yeah yes the scaling that showed was for
the maternal actually but um yes so the
the fact the the sort of factor out
front depends a lot on which kernel you
choose and it depends on the dimension
of your input space so it works really
well for one dimensional data and it
scales really badly with the number of
dimensions and and so yes it will but I
mean the scaling is is the same but the
constant factor quickly blows up yep we
use for your visor um so I actually
don't normally optimize I always sample
because because that's that's my jam but
um but I use sipe I minimize and it
works like [ __ ] is terrible you know but
optimization is hard right sit and so
you know you have to you have to be
somewhat careful with that of course yep
so none have been found and this is the
disclaimer I should have put at the
beginning ahem so still nothing has been
found I have only been working on this
for a few months so I don't I don't have
I don't have any results they look
promising the motivation for this is
that um that by not filtering we should
be able to recover by fitting the star
and the planet at the same time we
should be able to recover smaller
signals and that's been possible in in
synthetic data but I don't have any real
ones yet it's it yep
so hard for
my house
yeah so I so I explicitly don't do that
because i hate having to support that
but in the documentation i have examples
that show how to do it with matplotlib
and hopefully that's enough for people
but yeah that's not something that i
have in the code did you never have to
use another saltford very common and saw
me and I was gonna need is three ok I
wrap no idea ideal yeah I skipped IDL
yeah i just started with python alright
anyways thanks thank you